PROFESSOR: Today I'd like to
talk to you about some
techniques that you can add to
basic search to enable your
systems to make more intelligent
decisions and save
computation time.
Last time, we introduced basic
search and the basic idea of
how to encode search so that our
system can use search when
encountering an unknown
territory or state space.
And today, we're going to review
some things you can do
in terms of using the
information that you know and
also using estimations of the
information that you would
like to know to improve your
chances of discovering the
path that you're interested
in the fastest.
The first thing that we can do
in order to improve our search
is use dynamic programming.
Dynamic programming refers to
the idea is that once you've
done a computation for a
particular kind of problem,
you can save that computation
and use it later, as opposed
to having to engage in that
computation a second time.
The way this manifests in
search is that once you
visited a particular state, you
don't have to visit that
state again.
Because the way your agenda's
set up, you found the fastest
way to that particular state,
as far as you're concerned.
So the general idea is that once
you visit a particular
state, you don't have
to visit it again.
If you're building a normal
search tree, it can be
difficult to keep track of where
you've been, especially
if you're doing something like
that depth-first search.
To get around this and to enable
dynamic programming,
the easiest thing to do is just
keep a list of the states
that you visited as a
consequence of this particular
run of search.
I'm going to demonstrate dynamic
programming by running
depth-first search on
our state transition
diagram from last time.
The first two steps are the
same, except for the fact that
we're going to keep track of the
fact that we visited both
A, B, and C as a consequence
of the first two
iterations of search.
If I'm running depth-first
search, my agenda acts as a
stack, which means I'm going to
take the partial path that
I added most recently to the
agenda, pop it off, and expand
the last node in the
partial path.
When I expand C, I'm going to
visit B and D. However, B is
already in my list of states
that I visited, because it's
already in one of the partial
paths in my agenda.
So I'm not going to
visit B again.
Instead, I'm only going to add
one new partial path to my
agenda, ACD.
I'm also going to add D to my
list of visited states.
If I run another iteration
of depth-first
search, I find my goal.
For completeness, E is added
to list of visited states.
This took even fewer iterations
that the original
depth-first search.
We didn't waste time expanding
different nodes.
We also used less space.
In the general sense, the
concept of dynamic programming
is great to use whatever
you can.
And in search, it can save you
a lot of time and energy.
Another way we can intelligently
improve our
search technique is by making
considerations for costs that
we know that are associated with
particular transitions.
In this state transition
diagram, I've indicated some
costs associated with
the transitions
between particular states.
If we know the costs associated
with transitions,
then we can use a cumulation
of the weights accumulated
through traversing a particular
partial path to
prioritize which paths we're
going to explore first in an
effort to reduce the amount
of cost associated
with our final actions.
In order to do that, we can
keep track of the value
associated with that cumulation,
and sort the
agenda at every iteration
based on that cost.
If we're using dynamic
programming, while making
considerations for both cost and
heuristics, and also when
we're running the goal test when
making considerations for
cost and heuristics, we're
actually going to make our
considerations when we expand
the node as opposed to when we
visit the node.
This difference is very
important because it provides
us with the most optimal
solution.
If it's possible for us to visit
the goal node, but it's
100 cost units away, It may be
worth our while to search for
alternatives that provide
a much shorter
path to the goal node.
That's why we switch from
considering when we visit to
considering when we expand.
Let's look at uniform cost
search run with dynamic
programming.
In my first step, I expand
A and add two
partial paths to my queue.
I'm also going to keep track
of the cumulative cost
associated with that
partial path.
When I expand A, I add
A to the agenda.
Note that I haven't talked
about stacks or queues or
depth first or bread
first or anything.
We're working with
a priority queue.
And what that means is that
things with a higher priority
float to the top.
Or things with the lowest cost
associated with them we're
going to consider first.
This means that I'm going
to expand B in the
partial path AB first.
I'll add it to my list.
When I expand B, B has two child
nodes, D and C. ABC has
partial path cost 3 associated
with it.
And ABD has partial path cost
11 associated with it.
That means when I reprioritize
my queue, I'm going to end up
sorting everything such that
AC comes first, ABC come
second, And ABD comes third.
Previously, with our strategy
for dynamic programming, C
would not have been added to
this partial path, because
we've already visited
it with path AC.
At this step, we're going to
expand the path AC, add C to
the list, and any other time
that we end up visiting C, we
will not add it to our paths.
If I expand C, I have a
transition to B, which is
already in my list, and
a transition to D
that has cost 7.
ABC is going to float to the
top of my priority queue.
ACB is not going to be
considered, because B is
already part of my list.
And ABD is going to remain
with cost 11.
At this point, you might say,
but Kendra, why am I
considering partial path ABC
when C is in my list--
or C should be in my
list, excuse me--
as a consequence of expanding
the partial path AC?
Even though we've expanded the
partial path AC, if we have
not made any considerations to
weed out our list at every
iteration, this is still going
to float to the top.
And we're still going to have
to deal with it, even though
we've already expanded C. Since
we've already expanded
C, we're going to ignore this
partial path and just move ACD
7 and ABD 11 up to the front.
D is not in our expanded list.
When we expand D, we have one
child node E. Because we're
working with cost and
heuristics, we do not actually
evaluate the goal test
when we visit a node.
We evaluate it when
we expand a node.
So I am going to add
ACDE to my agenda.
It's going to have cost 8.
And ABD11 is still going to hang
out here at the back of
the priority queue.
At this point, I get to expand
E. I skipped adding D to the
expanded list when I expanded
it from ACD to ACDE.
At this point, I'm going to
expand E. And the first thing
I'm going to do is test and see
whether or not it passes
the goal test.
At that point, I stop search,
return that I successfully
completed the search, and
that my partial path
is going to be ACDE.
That covers uniform
cost search.
At this point, you might say,
Kendra, this is bearing a lot
of similarity to things
like maps.
And I would really like to be
able to use my knowledge of
things like the Euclidean
in order to make more
intelligent, even more
intelligent decisions about
where it is that I
go with myself.
And I would say yes, you
should be able to.
In fact, people do.
In fact, people do
all the time.
They say well, some
thing's this far
away as the crow flies.
So I know that if I've gone
further than that at any
point, then I've wasted
some amount of time.
But it represents a good
underestimate of the distance
that I'm going to cover.
This is the basic concept
of heuristics.
If you're attempting to find a
goal, and you have an estimate
for the remaining cost, but
you know it's not exactly
right, you can still use that
information to attempt to save
you an amount of computation
or amount of search.
In particular, you probably
shouldn't be using a
heuristic, if you know
it's perfect.
Because if you know the
heuristic is perfect, then you
should be using the heuristic
to solve your problems,
instead of doing search
in the first place.
Or if the heuristic already
tells you how long it's going
to take to find something, then
it probably also has the
path that represents how
long or that represents
that amount of cost.
If you want to use a heuristic
effectively, you have to make
sure that your heuristic
represents a non-strict
underestimate of the amount
of cost that is left over.
And what do I mean by that?
I mean that if you have a
heuristic, and you're using it
as a thing to tell you whether
or not you're wasting your
time, if your heuristic
represents information that is
bogus or says this particular
path has more cost associated
with it than it actually does,
then it will lead you astray.
Or you don't want to use a
heuristic that will prevent
you from using a path that
actually costs less than the
heuristic advertises.
This is what's known as an
admissible heuristic.
An admissible heuristic always
underestimates if it makes an
error in estimation about your
total distance to the goal.
All right.
So at this point, I've covered
dynamic programming.
I've covered costs.
I've covered heuristics.
And it turns out, you
can use all of these
techniques at the same time.
When you use both cost and
heuristics, in combination,
while evaluating your priority
queue, that's known as an
A-Star search.
And you'll see a decent amount
of literature on A-Star.
This covers all of the
intelligent improvements to
basic search that I will talk
about in this course.
We hope you enjoyed 6.01.